today we will talk about the program and
some of the topics that we will be
covering
we'll also discuss some of our previous
experience with these kinds of training
programs in bioinformatics
and hopefully answering any questions
that you have about the upcoming
program so armix logic transformatomics
is an
online training program for students
researchers
and clinicians and it is designed to
introduce participants to the various
aspects
of rna-seq data analysis in application
to basic research
as well as in biotechnology and
biomedical
applications so what i hope to do today
is speak a little bit about how rna-seq
is used for real world biomedical
applications
and research projects and what kinds of
skills
you need to have to be able to handle
large rna-seq data and be able to
visualize analyze and interpret this
data
to study different types of biological
phenomena
a little bit about omics logic and our
programs
so the omnix logic programs are a result
of a close collaboration between pine
biotech
our company which is based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result
the onyx logic programs have been
thoroughly tested and are known to lead
to excellent outcomes for students and
faculty
interested in learning bioinformatics or
incorporating bioinformatics resources
into existing programs these programs
combine experience in bioinformatics and
terminology
of biological data as well as
data science skills that are in high
demand in
industry we've been testing these
programs for
several years now and we feel that the
outcome
of these programs is very encouraging
because many of the participants that we
have joining these programs are
continuing on to apply the skills that
they've used
to their own research or even in
industry
so what is onyx omix technologies like
next generation sequencing
can be used to explore the roles
relationships
and actions of the various types of
molecules
that make up the cells of an organism
for example this is
an image of a cell which gives us
phenotypic data
about what these cells look like but
many types of omics data
can actually reveal molecular detail
about what is going on inside the cell
at the subcellular level
for example genomic data tells us about
variance at the dna level
epigenetic regulation of gene expression
has been uh of an increasing
interest for the past several decades
and today we can study this kind of
epigenetic regulation
by in the end by analyzing uh
chromatin immune precipitation data um
as well as bisulfite sequencing data
and the expression of micro and long
non-coding rnas
but ultimately we want to understand
how the cell which functions and grows
is regulating the different activities
based on expression of mrna messenger
rna
that could be studied through
alternative splicing
how different genes are spliced together
by combining exons as well as their
level of expression
which could be studied at both tissue
and single cell level so what we'll do
in this program is we'll talk about
some of the basics of rna-seq
how processing mapping and
quantification of rna-seq data
how to explore the gene and isoform
expression data and how to prepare the
data for analysis
what type of normalization techniques
and
data pre-processing techniques make an
impact on our ability to interpret what
is going on at the subcellular level
we'll discuss some of the statistical
approaches to
analyze differences between conditions
and identify statistically significant
features of our data sets how we can
then
look at what these features mean in
terms of their biological activity
and how we can combine them into gene
sets and pathways
and finally we'll talk about machine
learning so we'll talk about how
the advances in machine learning and the
easy application of machine learning
made through different packages and
interfaces
can allow us to study detailed patterns
within this large rna-seq data
so that we can interpret differences
between cell types
tissue types and different types of
conditions
as a method of measuring rna translation
transcriptomic studies can help detect
mrna expression
inside the cell as an accurate
alternative to membrane
protein expression detection which
allows for molecular precision
in diagnostics and even development of
treatment
based on molecular pathways
so when we think about rna-seq the
utility of
understanding what types of proteins are
being produced
provides us with a clear understanding
of what happens
inside beneath the membrane of an
individual
cell which is very different from when
we talk about
staining for proteins and biomedical and
diagnostic applications
and also provides us with a good insight
about potential
targets that could be targeted by
different drugs
as an important part of precision
medicine
this type of information is becoming
regularly useful
in different types of diagnostic
purposes for
early detection specific and
personalized
understanding of what's happening with a
patient at the subcellular level
what is driving the disease and
exploratory analyses
with model organisms and cell lines
where a functional association between
different genes and variation in those
genes could be
understood and studied at a mechanistic
level
so to allow us to study this kind of
technology
over the past few decades several
different technologies have been
designed
designed and rna-seq refers to
this next-generation sequencing
technology so rna-seq or rna
sequencing has revolutionized the way
biologists examine transcriptomes
and has been successfully applied in
biological research drug discovery
and clinical development compared with
microarray-based transcriptome profiling
rna-seq has a wider dynamic range
meaning that it can detect many more
variations of
the same genes so many more transcripts
of a gene
because it is not based on hybridization
so it's not based on
probes designed to measure and detect
specific types of
mrnas rnac can measure the expression
levels of
thousands of genes simultaneously and
provide insights
into functional pathways and regulatory
networks
in biological systems in addition rnac
can provide
novel insights into alternative splicing
unannotated exons and novel transcripts
that have not been previously annotated
most
importantly such detail has already
proven to yield
significant discoveries in many research
areas
gene expression patterns in association
with clinical data so when we have both
the gene expression data and different
types of phenotypic data described
by what condition this is or maybe even
described in a continuous numeric data
like for example
ld50 can help identify molecular
biomarkers for diagnostics and therapy
selection
like biomarkers and these new
discoveries also include a better
better understanding of complex diseases
for example like cancer that include
um aberrant expression and
changes in isoforms or exome splicing
and this understanding of these complex
diseases ultimately leads us to
appreciation of the variability of the
disease at an
individual patient level it is also
helpful to identify
targets for novel drug design and
repurposing and requires
an understanding of both the data
preparation
how the data is stored and annotated and
ability to find associations and measure
them
to be able to address these important
challenges
so in this program we'll discover how
rna-seq data can be used to study the
role of
tumor microenvironment in tumor growth
or
regulation which could be studied for
differentially expressed genes
in different types of conditions when we
compare
different conditions or control
experiments
and analyze to find markers of cell and
tissue types
in neuro neurodegenerative diseases
so we've prepared curated data sets and
projects
that we will be able to explore as we
learn
about the basics of rna-seq data
so this program our mix lodge of
transcriptomics
includes six sessions that are
interactive sessions
with a mentor they also include access
to a variety of different resources that
you will have access to during the
program
and an ability to work on an independent
project
so let's take a look at some of these
sessions and the topics that will be
covered
in these sessions in the first session
we will
describe all of the tools and resources
for transcriptomic data analysis so
we'll discuss a lot of different
material that was prepared
for the program specifically and how to
use
some of these tools in the next session
we'll discuss the basics of processing
next generation sequencing data
using what's called bioinformatics
pipeline so we'll discuss the concept of
pipelines
and we'll also discuss specific types of
pipelines
that can help us generate different type
of transcriptomic
data at the gene or isoform level
including bulk and single cell rnac
then we'll discuss an analysis
normalization and visualization of
genome and isoform expression we'll do
this using both cloud-based tools that
are intuitive and easy to use to
understand the logic of analysis and
also
discuss some of the typical packages in
both r and python
for analysis and visualization of such
data
in session four we'll introduce
big data mining and machine learning for
predictive analysis
so we'll discuss how the emergence of
big data in such studies like rna-seq
has led to an ability to mine publicly
available data sets
find interesting associations and
develop
novel hypotheses we'll also talk about
how machine learning
allows us to deploy machine learning
predictive models
to learn from data that is already
available
and predict something new about novel
data sets or data sets from other
repositories
that could be very useful for
classification
early detection and development of
biomarkers
in session five we'll speak about the
analysis of single cell rna-seq
how we can analyze single-celled data so
what kinds of
pipelines and standard packages exist
for the analysis and the processing of
the data
what are some of the challenges
associated with rna-seq data
what are some examples where analysis of
single cell data have
proven to be insightful and important
and also discuss
tissue specific expression so in fact
how we can take
markers from different tissues
discovered
through single cell rna-seq and apply
decomposition of bulk rna-seq data
in session six we'll take a look at a
few hands-on project examples
and these will be from the domain of
cancer biology
infectious diseases and biotechnology so
we'll provide a few different examples
and using these examples you'll be able
to develop
a project of your own and in that
project of your own
we will guide you how to find the data
how to then
process that data and prepared for
analysis
analyze and prove or disprove a
hypothesis
and then visualize and showcase the
results of your analysis
in an impactful way
now you can see on the chat there's a
link to a page where you can find
all of this information so all of the
questions about
what topics and sessions are included as
well as the
course costs and different options are
described on this page so let's take a
look at this page together
so this is the page thank you
okay so all you need to do is go to
transcriptomics.onyxlogic.com
so this is the page you can see that
it's going to start on 15th
of september we have four days and eight
hours and we're counting down to the
beginning of this program
and you can also start looking at
different sessions and topics that are
going to be covered in the program
and also the calendar of those sessions
so essentially we're talking about
two weeks in these two weeks we will
cover a lot of the basics in the first
week
and then go on to more advanced topics
in the second week
and then you will have another two weeks
to develop
and work on your independent project now
in many cases
when we interact with participants of
our program
they are interested in having a mentor
guide their selection of a data set help
them develop the project idea
and even help and assist to guide their
analysis
now we do have that option available as
well
so as we thought about how to structure
this program
we were thinking about different
packages that we could provide to
participants that could benefit the most
from completing a program getting
certification
developing a project idea and actually
applying some of these skills to a data
set or a research question
of their own so that's why if you go up
here
and you click on get started you will
see a few different options
which includes access to the program
courses
that we will take a look at in a second
access to our coding
exercise platform where you can code
learn how to apply
different packages and also get help and
feedback
on some of your code or errors that
you're getting
access to the interactive sessions where
we discuss
in detail some of these topics and
answer any kind of questions or discuss
any technical challenges that you have
also access to research projects in
other words you'll be able to
analyze your own data and get guidance
on the analysis of your own data from
a technical perspective and optional
mentor support so that
mentor support also means that you'll be
able to interact in a one-on-one session
with a mentor ask any questions get your
answers
and also be able to use that help to
make your project
better refined and more ready for prime
time for others to see
so those are some of the choices now if
you scroll down you will see as we
mentioned some of these
topics explained and here you'll see
some of the benefits from these programs
also down at the bottom there's some
feedback that we've gotten in the course
of our previous programs that you can
take a look at
and the description of the coursework
that we will go through
in detail in this presentation
so the omixlogic programs include a
variety of resources
that you can benefit from and also be
flexible
with your schedule making the most of
your time
for this program on transcriptomics we
will combine
online sessions self-guided study
materials
that you can complete on your own time
and
practical assignments and as a result we
hope that everyone will be benefiting
from
an immersive experience and what we've
seen in the past
is that the most of these elements
actually work seamlessly together
to have an effective outcome for our
previous and ongoing omics logic
programs and we have a few others that
are ongoing
as well that i'll be able to share in a
little bit
so let's look at some of these resources
one by one
throughout the program you will be
accessing
some of these online asynchronous
resources
that provide a broad and yet detailed
overview
of processing statistical analysis
and machine learning tools as well as
understanding of single cell data types
and
analysis techniques the courses cover
methods
expand on the specific terminologies
associated with each type
of analysis or data and provide
practical examples
they also include quizzes for
self-evaluation
and assignments so let's take a look at
some of these courses
and what they include
okay so this is a link specifically to
the different collections of courses
throughout the program you'll have
access to
many of these courses not all but many
of them
but specifically we will focus on this
collection of transformative
courses so you can read here about each
individual course and what it includes
as a part of the program all of these
resources are going to be free for you
um and they actually fit in very nicely
into the program schedule that we have
looked at already
so in transcriptomics one we discuss
what is next generation sequencing and
how is it different from first
generation sequencing
we also talked about the biology of mrna
expression
and how it could be related to different
pathways
and signaling in metabolic pathways at
the subcellular level that we need to
or seek to understand by not by
analyzing such data
in transcriptomics 2 we turn to
statistical analysis so we discuss
how statistics has been utilized to
understand
the differences between conditions or
groups of
samples and what are some of the
considerations around
doing that kind of analysis and
interpreting the results
we also talked about annotation
biological imitation of pathways
and gene ontology terms and think about
different applications in a variety of
directions
in transcriptomics 3 we turn to machine
learning
and machine learning as you know is
divided up broadly into two
types unsupervised or data mining
and supervised or classification so we
discuss
a few examples based on some practical
applications in the context of precision
medicine
how can we understand and classify
build a classifier that can predict
different types of subtypes of cancer
in transcriptomics four we turn to
single cell data
this is a new technology there are still
different methods in development but
there are
but there have been some established
pipelines that are now being
standardly used to process and produce
a table of single cell gene and isoform
expression data
because that data comes from a very
different type
of data preparation method you also have
to have a number of considerations when
you look and analyze the patterns
that have been made through that kind of
a processing pipeline so that's what
this course is all about
in addition to the online courses this
program is designed to give you a sense
of practical
analysis tools and we want to make this
as approachable and as useful for a wide
variety
of participants both those that do have
some
technical background like coding and
those that do not
but most importantly we're going to be
analyzing
big data sets so these are going to be
tens of samples
at a time as you know a single sample
of rnac data could range anywhere
between hundreds of megabytes to
a number of gigabytes and so processing
such datasets on your own computer
is going to be time-consuming and
ineffective
so as a part of the omixlogic
transcriptomics program you will have
access
to the t-bioinfo platform that provides
an interactive learning experience
the platform is color coded to help
establish
a logical connection between the
theoretical aspects of data analysis
methods
and the practical steps to achieve a
biologically
interpretable results so this is what's
called the bioinformatics pipeline
in this pipeline every step of the way
you will get an informative pop-up that
explains
the logic of why we are performing a
certain step
discusses the inputs and outputs of
every step
along the way and guides your
processing so that you can understand
what are the typical mistakes that you
can avoid by focusing on the correct
method
for the correct data set with the right
type of an output in mind
as a result instead of spending time on
building the pipeline
you get the ability to practice the
pipeline application
different methods with different types
of settings
produce different types of outcomes and
results and so you will benefit from
making those results throughout the
program and being able to explore how
these results could be interpreted
from a biological perspective
now what's important is that many
different pipelines are designed to
produce
different types of outputs and we can go
to a very
detailed read level analysis where we
can understand the mapping quality
and the read alignment for different
types of data that is being prepared
to then understanding the outputs or the
gene expression
table gene or isoform expression table
we'll talk about how to read these
different types of outputs
visualize them and also perform analysis
to summarize
and explore the specific patterns within
the data that we prepare
in transcriptomics three we'll dis
we'll spend a significant time to
understand
machine learning or data mining and
classification
with the exponential growth of data many
are turning to machine learning to study
complex relationships
at the subcellular level and develop
data-driven research
with important outcomes for human health
so in this program we'll have a chance
to see machine learning
in action including data mining
techniques like clustering
dimensionality reduction like principal
component analysis
classification like random forest and
support vector machines
and feature selection algorithms that
are both
stepwise greedy and selection based
so we'll cover a wide variety of topics
that are related to
both processing these big data sets then
analysis from a statistical perspective
and understanding how these more complex
machine learning methods
are practically applied in really clear
examples which i'll talk about in a
second
so let's take a look at how this process
will actually work
during this program you'll have access
to
the t by info platform now all of you
whether you're going to be a participant
in the program or not
are welcome to try this platform by
requesting a demo account
if you do request a demo account you'll
immediately get access to the interface
where you can explore a variety of
different sections
including next generation sequencing
data mass spectroscopy
structural biology and data integration
and modeling let's take a look at the
rna-seq
section to understand what it will look
like
here we've prepared a number of
different examples you can see from
cancer cell line projects ankleman
disease which is a neurodegenerative
disorder
and patient-derived xenograft models to
understand the
effect of microenvironment changes on
tumor growth
inside the interface you can now select
different methods
to build a pipeline it all starts with
the start and here you will see how
different
types of methods that are described in
the
further sections are used for what types
of applications
you can then see that only a small
number of
options are highlighted and so based on
your preference
you can select pre-processing steps
that clean up the reeds and help you
focus on only
high quality reads eliminating
contamination
from such things as adapter ligation and
pcr amplification then we can look at
mapping techniques to the reference
genome or transcriptome
and develop a sense of how
high is the expression for a particular
gene or isoform
ultimately looking at the gene
expression
table so once this pipeline is complete
you'll be able to see some of the output
files and we'll discuss
downstream analysis i'm going to pause
here and i see that there's a few
questions so i'll just briefly address
those questions if you have any
questions about what i've shown so far
please put them in the chat
okay so how will all of these
topics be covered in six sessions only
as a result of combining the interactive
sessions
which are about one and a half hours
long
together with the asynchronous material
that you will have access to on your own
we expect that you will be able to get a
very good understanding of many of the
topics that i'm discussing here
and also try to apply them to an
independent project
however the whole program is about a
month long
so if you don't have a lot of time on
your hands you will have
additional time after the interactive
sessions
to go through the synchronous material
and review the recorded sessions which
will be posted on the forum
so that you can make the most out of the
time after the interactive sessions
have been completed
okay what is the rna-seq pipeline so
what you're looking at now
is the rna-seq pipeline a pipeline
means that data from a script
or a job has been submitted to the net
script
and in a sequential manner the pipeline
produces
outputs that are used by the next
consecutive method
to give you the final output so this is
called
a pipeline now beyond this pipeline
which
seeks to produce structured data from
unstructured data
which comes out directly from the
sequencer
we will also look at how to analyze such
data
for example we can look at
the data in the gene expression table
to study different patterns and even
visualize them
because there's so many elements to
analyze this could be done
in an automated way using different
types of scripts
okay about my voice breaking i'm really
sorry about
maybe the connection quality is not that
great um
and i think if anyone else has this
issue
please let us know we'll also provide a
recorded version of this webinar
you can hear is there any change media
you can
you can hear me fine uh yeah we can hear
you clearly
thank you okay great is there any chance
of publishing the paper or data in case
of research project package
yes the objective for those that select
the research package
is to provide you with an opportunity to
develop an
independent project and make sure that
that project
gets to a level of completion when you
can actually
analyze the data and showcase what you
have discovered
now as you know publication itself
requires additional steps like peer
review and replying to different
questions from your
peer review process so we are not going
to guarantee that you're going to be
able to publish
but we have definitely seen a number of
participants
that have been able to achieve
meaningful results
and we even have a few examples on our
uh on a page maybe beep so you could put
paste a link to the project description
with a few examples of participants that
have made
excellent projects sometimes these
projects take a longer time
and so we also have an internship or
what we call a research
fellowship program that's intended for
three to six
months and during that time you have
plenty of
opportunities to interact with mentors
and a community of like-minded
bioinformaticians
that are going to help you make the most
out of your independent project
so beeps if you have the link to the
internship page that would be also
useful right now
so another part of what we will do is
use
a coding platform now coding itself
in both r and python is very meaningful
and useful for anyone that is interested
in bioinformatics now some of you might
already have some skills in basic r
and python but what we seek to provide
in this program
is an opportunity to learn apply
and combine together different scripts
to make the most out of the data so let
me show you how that would work
throughout this course in the program
itself
you'll have access to tutorials that
will explain
how to load data and check the different
data types
perform exploratory analysis doing
descriptive statistics and visualization
and then focus on dimensionality
reduction
differential gene expression
hierarchical clustering
and different methods of classification
so as you go on to this platform you'll
find that inside
you will have some explanation in both
r or python on how to perform these
steps
learn about different types of code
and syntax and then apply this
to a data set that is described
in the program itself so when you
learn how to do this you will actually
be able to
run a code
you will get errors or success and also
will be able to monitor
and record your progress as you go
through this process
so for example here i have just prepared
some summary plots that allow me to
understand what my data looks like and
by
changing some of these examples i can
also modify
how this is going to look in the end so
for example here you can see i can
change the colors
or change which data set i'm going to be
using
and for example let's just change
briefly
this code from red to blue
okay and you can see that we got a blue
box plot
so those are the types of exercises that
you'll be able to go through
and this is also going to be included
for a whole month
and after that month you'll have a
discounted subscription option if you're
interested to continue and learn
not only these things in the context of
rna-seq
but also our full data science
curriculum
most importantly i believe that you
actually understand the most
of the significance of rna-seq and
understanding gene expression from a
biological perspective
when you get to apply this to data sets
that make sense
to data sets that you understand the
challenge and where you understand what
the data
was prepared to do so we'll take a look
at a number of
interesting examples taken from high
impact
journals that are peer-reviewed we'll
take the data and we'll also discuss how
to find such data on repositories like
ncbi
and look at them in the context of
different types of applications for
example for cancer we'll talk about
patient-derived cell lines
patient-derived xenograft models and
clinical trials and translational
applications
in repositories like the cancer genome
atlas or tcga
in depth we'll go into some examples
where we discuss
what are the challenges for example in
breast cancer classification it's
important to
rely on molecular subtypes to discuss
different treatment options and risk
associated with different types of
therapies so we'll talk about how these
different
subcellular profiles can help us
identify
molecular classes and what do those
classes mean
in the context of diagnostics and
treatments
can we download the sessions and other
inputs for a future reference of course
we will provide you and i will get to
that
in a second it will provide you with
recorded materials from all of the
sessions
you will get access to all of our course
material that is also available in a pdf
format and you'll also get access to the
data sets
that we have practiced and used
throughout the session so you will have
that
after this program is over
one of the projects that we'll discuss
is modeling precision
medicine in cancer so here we will take
a paper
that is called modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer where
a number of different cell lines were
prepared and
accessed by the researchers from the
public domain
and developed a classifier that
accurately predicts
how responses to different treatments
will be
based on the molecular profile but also
by using training data
from response and measurement of
um inhibition of growth 50 so
50 of the inhibition of growth as a
result if you look just through the
article uh itself you'll see how we will
learn about
molecular profile uh what are these
features
how to predict therapeutic responses
what are optimal predictors what is
molecular path of biology
omics data and how to select most
predictive molecular feature sets
so you'll get access to a number of
projects that are really broken down
and clarified in terms of what is the
objective
what is the data and how to apply the
different methods of analysis
to discover such important path patterns
and be able to speak about them and
present
them to your peers now many of our
previous participants have been able to
leverage these programs
to then go on and start discussing the
projects that they have worked on
in the context of their future journey
so here you can see some of the previous
participants of our programs that had a
chance to
present at conferences and by the way i
want to mention that right now
for these kinds of online programs this
is a good time because you can actually
present
virtually in many conferences that are
upcoming if you are interested to
publish
a poster session is probably going to be
your first step to validate and get some
feedback on your idea
after that as you develop your passion
in a particular
area or maybe you all already have maybe
you're already
using rna-seq and data analysis skills
for a particular
type of projects you can then
build on your expertise in other areas
to advance your research career
for example we have seen a number of
participants
that have come from either bachelor
degree
master degree post doc or phd
or post docs that have been able to
benefit from the program
for example olga udartseva from roswell
park comprehensive cancer center
mentioned that the program from her
perspective is very well structured and
easy to learn
the skills that she gained through the
program helped me significantly enhance
the relevance of my project by making
connections
between my pre-clinical study and its
practical applications to cancer
patients
so we're not just talking about learning
about rna-seq
our goal is to empower you to then apply
the different bioinformatics tools
repositories
and data sets to actually make research
discoveries
and apply them to practical problems
now she's not the only participant that
have provided with such feedback we
believe that
that we have had in our previous
programs have been able to benefit from
these programs and as a result we have
them available both
in this online fashion where you can
just
join online or through different
universities
for example in louisiana we are offering
such
training through the louisiana
biomedical research network
in india we have partner institutions
that are able to provide these courses
to their participants as well as a new
program that we are launching in africa
with a number of partner universities
that are going to offer such
coursework and resources to their
students
so the program is going to be starting
on september 15
so that's just in four days from now
remember that you'll have access to
processing pipelines we'll discuss
different methods of visualization and
how to build that visualization using
different types of packages coding
skills as well as
tools we'll discuss statistical analysis
approaches how to
do hypothesis testing and how to
interpret the results
we'll discuss data mining how do we mine
the complex
big data sets that are available online
with thousands of samples and how to
extract
meaningful uh patterns and meaningful
associations from that kind of data
and then we'll also talk about
interpretation what are some tools
that can aid us in visualizing our
results
and being able to interpret them by
using different
reference databases for annotation
at this point i would like to ask if you
have any questions or if i could
clarify any part of the program itself
the omics logic transcriptomic program
will
allow you to learn about rna-seq data
processing analysis and
interpretation leverage cloud-based
tools for hands-on assignments
apply machine learning to large
biomedical data sets
complete and present an independent
research project and
obtain a certificate of excellence and
gain recognition
from our community
and if you have any questions please
paste them on chat
i want to briefly mention how the
program is structured
and for those of you that have already
registered i know that
many people have already registered for
the program so just to
explain what would be the next steps
once you are registered you will gain
access to
our program page and this is the program
page all mixed logic transformations
2020.
here you will see courses that are
included in the program
project examples progress where we track
the progress
and you can also evaluate your progress
from
a perspective of the rest of the group
attract assignments and also see the
syllabus
and the faculty of the program
we also utilize the forum on this forum
we will be
pasting session recordings highlighting
top performers
and also pasting any additional
information that we think is beneficial
to those
that are interested in rna-seq so these
are going to be publications
different types of review articles
and data sets that we are utilizing in
the program
about financial support we are very
interested in helping
anyone who is passionate about learning
bioinformatics
gain skills and apply them in a
meaningful way
we offer scholarships for those that
have the time and the dedication to go
through these programs and
develop an independent project you
are welcome to reach out to marketing at
pine.bio with any clarification
about uh offers for a scholarship
um so you do have to have some previous
background in either molecular biology
or
some kind of bioinformatics so that you
are
comfortable with the materials and you
have to be
please email marketing at pine.bio
so on this page you will see all of the
relevant materials this page is going to
be
available to those that have already
registered you'll see
the upcoming schedule for each one of
our sessions
and you'll also see any kind of activity
here
and get help from our mentors to address
any technical challenges throughout the
program
after completing this program can
participate apply for scholarship
programs
you can definitely apply there's a
variety of different scholarship
options um i also want to mention that
we do have
a linkedin group and a facebook group
that we invite you to join maybe so you
could post those links
in those groups we regularly post
opportunities for
uh different types of internships or
even job
offers um in terms of scholarships so
as i mentioned before we do have a
a program for internships
let me just open that one
which is a research fellowship that is
either
three or six months conducted completely
online
for those of you that might be
interested in that
in the research fellowship you gain a
lot of
assistance from like-minded
bioinformaticians as well as from our
team
to help you develop an independent
project and complete it in the course of
time that you're registered
for and we believe that if you're
interested in
a scholarship program or you're
interested to get into a particular
program or a lab
typically what is required is for you to
come prepared
right a lot of pis a lot of universities
are looking for students that are
prepared that are ready
to start their job or start their
position running
and so we believe that developing a
project
in the specific topic of that lab or
that university or that
company can really help you advance
your career in that field
so we do offer uh support and access to
a lot of the tools
and regular weekly sessions that you can
join here
um you can again fill out the form on
this page if you're interested
specifically
in this you get access to all of our
learning materials
and by registering filling out this
registration form
you will start receiving emails about
the specifics and the details and we can
also schedule
a one-on-one meeting if you're
interested in joining that program to
evaluate the best fit
and discuss what you might want to do to
prepare for
such a program
okay so if there are no other questions
um i would like to also introduce
uh dr maheed mazumdar who is going to be
also helping with this program
mohit if you would like to say a few
words about the program
um or um anything you think might be
relevant at this point
thank you india uh hello everyone
yes uh for this transcriptomics program
uh
which will be starting on monday
we will be uh helping you out with uh
the registration on the website on the
portal
on the educational platform and give you
the access
to the courses that we described today
in the today's session and uh we will
have
uh we will be also sending you the
access to the tbi infoserver
account so that you can start applying
those methods
and see how you can
design uh those pipelines as well so uh
if you need any help uh regarding the
registration
uh do let us know if you face any
trouble uh reach out to us
at marketing at the red pine dot bio and
uh
we will be looking forward to uh have
you uh on
monday yeah thank you india
okay excellent thank you and thank you
everyone for joining today some of the
questions
um do you get a discount if you register
today
so please uh reach out to marketing at
pine buy
at pine dot bio uh you will see
when you get started there is an option
here to get a
coupon uh so if you are interested in a
discount or a scholarship you need to
discuss that with marketing
and pine dot bio we review every case
with a lot of consideration we're really
interested in
more than just a program that you walk
away with
with a certificate from we're interested
in building a community that continues
to learn together
and actually applies these skills to
different types of research projects so
we're definitely
happy to have everyone who's passionate
about bioinformatics on board
thank you for joining today again the
recording in the session will be made
available
there are other programs but all of them
are
in bioinformatics we do discuss aspects
of cellular biology immunology
infectious diseases etc but in the
context of data analysis
and we are very very passionate about
the data part of each one of those
topics that you've
mentioned um and in fact what we try to
do in our sessions
is not only discuss about the data
analysis methods and the statistics in
the computer side of things but we also
touch on many aspects of
cellular biology immunology and other
topics
that are important to understand when
you deal with biological projects in
biological data
any courses in cancer biology so in
uh the courses that we we have we
include
introductions to different types of
projects
so when we look at the um
let's look at the schedule here
we believe that in the beginning you
should get some basics
and be able to independently analyze
data
and so that's what the first part of
this program is going to be focused on
then we'll actually discuss a number of
project
examples and how to find publicly
available rnc
data so a lot of our examples are going
to be related to cancer
at both cancer biology and immunology in
the sense that
the cancer develops and then
causes disease in different areas of the
body
we do have a separate program on
oncology
which is not this program this is
specifically on transcriptomic but
transcriptomic data is
excellent to study cancer particularly
different types of cancer like breast
cancer etc
but we also apply the same
to the immunology of infectious diseases
when we look at the host response to
different pathogens
and we also discuss different types of
approaches to
agriculture understanding of differences
in crop production stress responses
and others so if you need a little bit
more information on the different types
of projects that we offer or that we
discuss
in the context of the program you can
take a look right here these are some of
the
some of the projects that you will have
as your practice
throughout the program you can see here
that we have identification of
novel pathogens in cell lines that are
used for biologic production
ebola virus some of these are not going
to be available for the whole public but
we will still rely on them in the
courses
crop drought stress and resistance
targeted medicine or cancer biomarkers
in early stage detection of breast
cancer
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's disease
analysis of changing immune responses in
cancer this is a study of macrophage
changes over time patient-derived
genograph models allows us to study the
microenvironment and tumor development
and
modeling precision medicine which i
already touched on in this course
now we do have a number of other
examples that we're going to be
doing including liver cancer
tuberculosis
as well as covid19 immunology
so there's a lot of material that is
prepared obviously in
such a short time we're not going to be
able to cover
everything but we will provide you
access with some curated data sets
and explain some of the basics that will
get you started
and help you develop an independent
project idea
and whether you select the package with
the mentorship or not
will try to work with you hands-on to
actually allow you to get the most out
of the program
okay so again thank you everyone for
joining it was a pleasure to
see so many people interested
um about the pre-requirements there's
not really any
major pre-requirements to just join the
program you do have to have some
basic uh well so
to join the program itself you do need
to have some basic terminology
in uh molecular biology uh in fact
what we recommend for everyone we have a
free course that is called
introduction to bioinformatics sorry
introduction uh to bioinformatics
that we recommend for everyone to start
with this is a free course
so you can actually join and register
today
and go to this introduction to
bioinformatics course now this course
is not your standard introduction to
bioinformatics where you learn the very
basics
it talks about different types of
applications different types of projects
different types of data sets it talks
about many different things in a very
short period of time
and you can see just based on the
reviews
how many different people have been able
to
benefit from completing this course
now after you go through this course you
will also get a sense
of what this these courses in general
are going to be
like and you'll see that even faculty
members
um at different universities were able
to benefit from
just completing this free course so it's
a free resource to get started
we also get to learn about you in this
course
and that helps us adjust our programs to
make sure that they are
providing great outputs for
those participants of our programs so
you can really
try to explore the materials here
provide us with some information about
your background your educational
background
your other experience in bioinformatics
and we will be reaching out to you based
on your feedback
from the course material itself but also
based on your
information
okay so hopefully i've been able to
answer all of the questions that you
might have
if you do have any other questions you
feel free to reach out to us by email
or complete this introduction to my
informatics course for free
and provide us with some more
information about you
we would be happy to stay in touch as
well
okay and we also offer a number of other
programs that are coming up
um briefly those are programs
in different parts of the world that
focus on the application of
bioinformatics
to different types of data as well as to
different types of challenges biomedical
epidemiology as well as agriculture
so please stay in touch we do about
two programs per month um and if you are
interested in a particular topic
we're always looking for new ideas
and to develop new programs thank you
and have a good rest of your day